こんにちは私はスティック古墳と申します
ご存知の方もいると思うんですが
ぬーん
既に何年間を続けて
英語主に英語で
言葉の勉強についていろんな話をしていますビデオ国へ youtube でリリーを
作っています
これからはですね
支部はい4号回連続日本語でその言葉の勉強について話ししたいと思います
最近をほとんど日本語を話ししてませんので
他の言葉さらう系の言葉
ロシア号くらいに語ポーランド語
あるいは韓国語を勉強しているから私の正
日本語の
あのあるいはその言葉遣いなんかはちょっと
レベルが落ちてると思うんですがまあそれは別として
もちろん日本ではですね言葉の勉強というのは英語英語の勉強
がほとんどのようですけれどもまあ残念ですけどね
私が15
a カ国の言葉を
話せるんですからやはり
一つの外国語だけじゃなくて第3第4も勉強すると
いろんな利点がありますが
ただそういうことをするにはあるいは英語だけでもエゴを言う遅漏に話すするにはです
ね色んなファクターがいるんですよ
いろんな佐野
まあ前景なんじゃ全血条件っていうか
るんですよでん
一つはですねやはり何をするにしてももちろん自信がないとダメなんでしょ
絶対できますとか
やりたいぞ
んですけれどもしかし自分がね体だ例えばスポーツの例を取りますとね
自分が弱いとか
耐久力がないとか技術がまあ技術は育つこともできるんですけれども
その力というか耐久療法は非常に大事なんですよ
それがやはり言葉の勉強の時にまた例えば英語勉強の場合はね
どうやって自分のこれスポーツなら身体を鍛えるでしょ
だけども言葉の勉強の場合はですねどうやって自分がその言葉の
九州動力ですか勉強の力を鍛えるかそれについてですねちょっと話したいですよね
私が寝始めて日本へ行ったのは1900まあ69年
結婚したすぐあとあのワイフと一緒にね
ちょっと始めただけです3日間くらい
東京に留まりましたけれどもあと71年から82年までその間にですね
まあ3年間はまだ花芽がにいたんですがほとんど日本にいたんですよ
だから9年間ディション日本に住んでたんですよ
で私は日本語の学校は行ったことないです
日本語の先生もいなかった私が日本についてから自分でいろんな
その方
使えて殺害の竹が使ってですね
日本語勉強しました
傘生きるとねブローチますけれどもでもちろんあの
話だけじゃなくてもう
読むことも大事ですからそして映画ない c あのその言葉の勉強に対して共鳴あり
ますので日本語のいろんな本を読んでますよ
もう歴史だとか
小説だってんだとかあるいは日本の勉強について英語の逆から学べとか
なぜあの人は人前で話すのがうまいのか
私の
英単語帳とか外国語上達法とか
まあ歴史の本もありますよ日本のルーズ
がわかる本とかマーカーアクションたくさんあるんですよ
だからその言葉の勉強自分の経験だけじゃなくていろんな人の意見
もちろん英語10日フランスは他の言葉でも似たような本のような部分もあるんですよ
送料ですね自分の経験そして他の人の経験を見て a
所の中からやはり
なんて言うんですかねこっちというか何が一番のキーポイントですか
症例についてですねこれからこういう上でお手
およそいい
4分間号五感の間で説明したいと思います
え
これが皆さんの役に立てば非常に幸いだと思います
お前やとじゃまたねあの
皆さんとのもう会は楽しみにしています
さようなら